[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum ryan teos is here hi
hi ryan hello it's good to see you good
to see you
like you uh your hair is growing it is
growing a little beard it looks like a
um
josh brolin's dad
uh james brown james james brolin but a
younger james berlin a younger james
real handsome young amityville horror
james brolin i'll take it anybody seen
that movie i will take it i loved it uh
hey i hope you're enjoying your week
thank you for spending an hour with us
um
means a lot if you like the interview
today
or you don't like it i ask you to
subscribe
uh write a review it really truly helps
the podcast and uh it means a lot it
means a lot there's so many competitors
so many people out there and you know we
want to keep doing the show and also you
can join patreon if you really want to
help the podcast
that's patreon p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot com
slash inside of you people give back to
the podcast it's also a huge community
and a lot of people become friends it's
really
amazing check it out there's different
tiers where i send you boxes and prizes
and all sorts of [ __ ] and we have
youtube lives and
zooms and it is just everything go to
patreon.com inside you can support the
podcast if you will
and you can also go to the inside of you
online store
you know that yeah yeah inside you
online store you can get uh small the
lunch box uh a lexmas autographed script
from me what about something like that
that you're wearing right now you can
get that no you can't get this
sweatshirt is a little zippy thing and
you show a little chest hair can i do
that a little bit oh damn right it's
getting too sexy i'm sorry
too sexy for my inside of you jacket
um but you can get a lot of great stuff
there inside of you stuff and i
appreciate it and you can also go to
sunspin.com that's the name of the band
sunspend and you can get a bunch of
merch there and book zooms with me and
rob it's always a blast we just zoomed
with leanne and michelle that was a fun
time all right also
uh if you like the show follow us you
can follow us on uh tell them about it
ryan uh inside if you pod on twitter
inside of you podcast on facebook
yeah you know you know where to go
facebook you guys know where to go right
it's right facebook and instagram uh it
means a lot so support the podcast and
uh it takes a second to go follow us and
write a review and subscribe or you can
do all of it really quickly so
today's guest chris diamantopoulos now
listen i if you don't know him you're
gonna thoroughly enjoy this interview i
love this interview this guy
floored us with impressions floored us
with impressions my god uh the three
stooges uh robin williams impression he
was in the three stooges and that story
of how they treated him
was astonishing yeah i can't wait for
you to hear that they didn't pay the guy
a cent
uh he's the voice of mickey mouse he's
in red notice on netflix the guy is
blowing up he's a super talent i loved
having him in the podcast
if you don't know him have a listen
let's get inside of chris diamantopoulos
it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience actually this is really nice
it's a nice setup you like the setup i
have a a home studio too and and i i put
uh a tremendous amount of time and and
effort into it particularly you know
once we realize we're in all this uh and
and um
this covet thing this covid thing it was
gratifying to do but i have to say i
think i think what you've done here see
i i focused a great deal of time
on the technical aspects being you know
because i've recorded so many i have to
i'm recording so many series from in
there right i wanted it to be sort of so
you're recording like you do a lot of
animation and you're doing all the
animation from your own home studio all
of it yeah yeah i did a whole season of
uh wonderful world of mickey mouse there
and you play the voice of mickey mouse
well hot dog i sure do
and you auditioned for that of course i
did and i actually passed on the
audition i got the audition right after
i had done the three students fairly
brothers three students moving well i
tested for that did you know
they're the one you got you would have
been great but you look like you could
be a mo you got the eyebrows you got the
you know i i i'm a lifelong stooge fan
as a matter of fact the first
public speaking engagement i ever did
when i was in grade six in toronto we
were supposed to do a speech 20-minute
speech each kid was supposed to do one
at the end of the year right kids did
like everglades or volcanoes i did
moe howard uh and it's been my life jump
into mo howard any time what are you
complaining about what are you talking
about here you know dude i mean for me
moe was
uh mo was oh my god mo wu tv buffalo 29
that was mo
i love actors ryan ryan the engineer
here ryan is my main man my main man
thinking then
i love when actors can do impressions
i've always done impressions and
sometimes you bring an actor on here and
they go no i don't i don't do
impressions but you come you come in
here the first thing you see is indiana
jones come on and you start doing the
crusade just do give me a little piece
of that yeah it's um
last crusade i wasn't always shared
you're old enough to be her grandfather
well i'm as human as the next man i was
the next man
ships that passed the night
remember the last time we had a quiet
drink what are you talking about we
never talked
it's the lonely way to grow up dad if
you've been an ordinary average guy like
the other guy's fathers you'd have
understood that actually
i was a wonderful father
when
did i ever tell you to clean up go to
bed wash your ears do your homework no i
respected your privacy and i taught you
self-reliance all right we'll stop there
that's amazing yeah well i mean the the
amazing thing is that that's all that's
in there and i think it'll be a quick
transition between this and senility
you know
i think so i think it'll be pretty
seamless i'll just drift off into that
beautiful little you know magical uh
memorize there's like like
you know a good 15 16 movies that are
just locked in there and i'll just live
in there what are some other movies that
are locked in there oh man well the
court jester danny k the court gesture
that's that's the first one that was
ever locked in there if you haven't seen
it no no so you should yeah nineteen
[ __ ] k though dancer right so he was
danny k was everything as a matter of
fact at his height danny k was the top
movie star tv star radio star
and broadway star wow he was he was uh
tremendously facile with his mouth and
he did these amazing uh tongue twister
songs and scenes that actually his wife
sylvia fine was was the author of most
of them right have you ever heard the
pellet with the poisons in the vessel
with a pestle the child's from the
palace is a brew that is true oh he's
he's just he's just this he was he was
everything for me when i was nine years
old and i saw the court jester that was
it so first it was the stooges right the
stooges was that that was my life so you
memorized all that stuff there was so
wutv buffalo 29 had like a good
i want to say they had like 40 or 50
stewed shorts that they would air in
syndication now you're watching this in
toronto yep in toronto in toronto you're
getting this station buffalo 29 and
that's where you're watching all this
stuff that gets just lodged into the
brain as a matter of fact it's it's wtv
buffalo 29 that's the reason that i
don't have a canadian accent because i
learned i'm greek and my first language
was greek at home but i learned how to
speak english watching my favorite
american actors so i never developed a
canadian accent because i wanted to
sound just like harrison your friends
your friends have canadians absolutely
how do they talk
well so most of my friends in toronto
many of my friends in toronto are greek
canadians so they would they'd say look
i'm sorry but i grew up in toronto so
you know this is how i how i talk you
know so
you know it's okay sorry yeah i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry you're not
you're not cool with that
um
yeah no but it was really i i i i was
imitate fully imitating uh uh the
american accent wow and so and it i
guess it boded well but yes memorized
too many jerry maguire is one that's in
there for some reason that's a great
jerry maguire man you gotta give it
because people like this we don't get a
lot of people that do impressions and i
feel like i'm already always reiterating
or spitting out old impressions that i
do
so people i'm sure they would like to
hear some of this so give me a little
jerry mcgregor god jerry maguire it's
it's just such a great uh
i uh let's let's give you a little i
love um i love when he says
um
you see this coat well i don't need it
you can have it because i am cloaked in
failure i love cloaked in failure is is
is a line that i view any time my wife
i'm walking out of an audition she's
like how'd it go
well it's either you know great or close
yes yes no the other one that comes from
that is it is an up at dawn pride
swallowing siege that i will never be
able to fully tell you about okay rod
puppet dawn pride swallowing siege those
are that's also amazing a good audition
story i do a very you know the obscure
ones like like oh oh wait wait wait was
she a great big fat person
put the lotion in the basket or against
the hose again don't you hurt my
precious lady you don't know what pain
is you know stuff like that that's
phenomenal lawrence tourney here are
your names mr blue mr brown mr pink what
am i gonna be mr pink for cause you're a
well well i can't say it yeah you can't
say it that's very good but i never lost
my eyes and i'm there i never left the
house i would always do isn't mr brown a
little close to mr [ __ ] that's your name
i i just i wouldn't leave that i'd get
so enamored by movies totally that i
would just you know i'd get lost i think
that was a way to escape for me as a kid
right braveheart was a big one for me
too braveheart i just recently watched
braveheart for the first time yes does
it hold up it does it was really fun the
trouble with scotland is that it's full
of scots
perhaps it's time to reinstitute an old
custom
grant them prima doctor
first night i mean it's really [ __ ]
i'm sorry we're not allowed to swear on
this yeah you could swear oh yeah oh god
you can swear when you really stop and
think about it most of my guests don't
they don't no no no i'm kidding no they
do they do
people swear right you swear oh gosh oh
there you go in fact ryan was just
quoting you
he was like oh dude he's from the
silicon valley yes and i go oh yes and
the first thing i say well what do you
know about silicon valley and what did
you say ryan oh it's this guy [ __ ]
there it is that's it and you know it's
funny i look at ryan because i walked in
here and i looked at you and no no no
disrespect but i think ryan's the guy in
the house doing all the [ __ ]
ryan is doing all the [ __ ] but what a
classic line do you have people come up
to you and say oh my god yes so much i
mean this guy [ __ ] is that right
this guy [ __ ] when i lived in new york
city
it's when i really realized oh my gosh
yeah that there that character and that
particular russian cinnamon russ
hannemann resonated so much with this
sort of 18 to 55 year old you know
startup vc bro demographic and it's
listen i i think it's i think it's
lovely when when you as an actor do
something that resonates with with the
fan base
it's it's gratifying it's challenging
when i'm walking my six-year-old
daughter and someone's like hey this guy
[ __ ] and she's like what do you say
daddy i'm like he said this guy's a fox
and she's like that's equally weird dad
equally
really weird yeah but that's cool though
when people recognize you and say oh my
god it's a signature yeah you know
there's a signature line it and and you
know
look i have
i'm so
i'm so lucky i've i've only ever acted
in my life i've never held another job
since you were like nine right yeah i
did it did commercials and and uh and
your parents were all for this so my
folks and i do have to [ __ ] give it
to my parents man because my parents are
lovely educated traditional greeks they
they don't have a concept of you know
sort of like they're not stage parents
they didn't understand any of it what
they did fully recognize almost before i
did was that i had a keen desire to
entertain and and they knew
that they had to do something about that
what what was that were you were you
doing impressions like you were for me
just now yeah are you always what were
you doing yeah i made them think that i
was doing i i when we would go to greece
in the summers we didn't have a tv where
and and my parents would just have me
reenact stooges shorts you know uh and
and it was it was just they saw that it
was more than just me messing around
they actually saw that there was skill
there and uh and i remember my mom
signed me up for this improv class that
was just this it was the saturday
afternoon thing that she
read about in the paper and i ended up
getting an agent from that and and
started to do commercials and that was
it was a fun little i had like a little
moment like 9 to 11 i actually did a lot
of local commercials in toronto and then
and then when people were recognizing
you it really started happening are you
the rice krispies guy hey you're the
honda commercial guy you know it was a
little thing it was sweet but then
puberty slapped me in the face like a
[ __ ] sledgehammer and and overnight i
went from like precocious attractive
commercial kid to
oh my god what happened to you man oh
awkward just as awkward as could be my
my one of my head shots from that era my
brother describes as the
shaken awake sprayed in the face with
crisco and hair lit on fire uh that's
that's what i how i want to see a
picture i got to find out now i got to
see this picture one small eye one big
one big eye
uh and it was really really bad but that
was the best thing that ever happened to
me because it made me realize that okay
so
i'm not going to be remembered for my
looks it's got to be something else and
i started really a deep dive into and
that's where danny kay came into play
because his was his was a facility with
language and with music and with as you
said with with dance and song and and so
i started really getting into musicals
and really started getting into stage
performance and and uh and i i went into
it with great aplomb i really wanted to
be like bing crosby or gene kelly
well it's funny because you played
sinatra in the kennedys that's true i
did i did so
you have a knack for that kind of old
school feel is that is that what you're
saying i love that vernacular that era i
think yeah 30s 40s 50s sweetheart kind
of thing there's something about the way
that they spoke the cadence there was a
music musicality to it there was a
romance to it i had the the distinct
pleasure of doing a a
such an odd project that was just so
beautiful because it was a singular
opportunity i did one of these uh
televised live musicals i did the
christmas story live for [ __ ] scares
the [ __ ] out of me oh it's the listen
i'm a broadway veteran right i i did
eight shows a week for 15 years right
and that's full monty i did i did lame
as a rob i did the full monty i did uh
waitress uh right but but i'll tell you
that christmas story live was the most
harrowing and exhilarating experience uh
performance experience i've ever done
because you play i played the old man i
played old man parker oh great which was
and you know when yeah yes exactly right
when when uh when scott ellis called me
about it i was like really i don't i
think i'm like 20 years too young dude
and he said no no it's a musical it's
not we're not redoing the movie we're
redoing the broadway musical i didn't
know that they had done a musical and
and when i when i sort of looked at it
he said you know you've gotta you gotta
be able to sing and dance and and and i
thought about it i was like i love scott
ellis i think he's a brilliant director
and i'd worked with maya maya rudolph
and i had done up all night together i'm
in love with her i think she's just a
great off-again boyfriend i did i played
and i created that guy they were like we
don't know what this guy we want this
guy to be and we made him my armenian
tailor he was this guy ava
don't call me my friend my friend
he's yeah yeah yeah he's the guy who had
a a beautiful bathroom with a yakutsi
tub yeah um but you had to sing i mean
are you a good singer i am a good singer
you're a good singer i'm a good singer i
you know i spent listen i spent years
and years and years on broadway honing
my voice so yeah it turns out
that i uh
i i can sing
inside of you is brought to you by my
good friends at betterhelp betterhelp
online therapy is uh somebody a company
that's been with me for a while now and
um
if you listen to the podcast you
understand why they're really helping
people they're helping people like my
friend ryan here ryan you still go to
better help i still go to better help
and how much is it helping you it is
helping immensely yeah a lot of my
friends are like is this was this real
the real deal is better help i'm like
yeah man that's a lot of people are
using it and really liking it i get
letters
all the time sent to me
that say hey thanks for you know your
better help uh
sponsor because they're really helping
me yeah and you know you definitely save
a lot more than going to you know just
getting in your car and going somewhere
um
you know those
therapy sessions are expensive as hell
yeah and better help is definitely a lot
cheaper
you know many people think that therapy
is for uh
other people
but utilizing therapy doesn't mean
something's wrong with you it means you
recognize that all humans have emotions
and we need to learn to understand them
not avoid them
and we've been taught
that taking care of our mental health
shouldn't be a part of everyday life but
that's a huge misconception
we take care of our bodies by exercising
going to the doctor eating well
focusing on and investing in the health
of our minds
is just as important
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to ryan do you see them
on camera i do you like that i like it i
think it helps for me it helps for you
like to see the person it's more of a
some contact some interaction it just
feels
hey you just see some kind empathetic
faces across from you yeah i like that
no uh like i said it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you could be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours look give it a try so
many people have tried this two million
people have been using better help
online therapy and inside of you
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com
slash inside that's right ten percent
off for inside of your listeners off
their first month at betterhelp.com
inside that's betterhelp h-e-l-p-com
slash
inside inside of you is brought to you
by creatures of habit that's with a k
ryan no creatures of habit is an
in-your-face lifestyle and wellness
brand rooted in delivering nutritional
healthy habits alongside cozy apparel
the founder's story is one of hope
change adversity and now success
michael chernow made a decision 17 years
ago to change his life from struggling
with addiction and mental health to
living a life of wellness it wasn't as
easy as it sounds but the choice to find
a few healthy habits to commit first
thing in the morning was his gateway
into a better way of living one of those
habits was oatmeal that's right and he
stuck
with it as his first meal of the day for
all these years when he launched koh he
set out to develop the most delicious
and healthy first meal of the day that
included oats of course but he added
protein and daily supplements so that he
could help people get everything
essential our body needed all in one
product meet the protegonus get that
like oat like in the middle protagonist
an incredibly delicious highly optimized
superhuman oatmeal packed with 30 grams
of plant-based protein vitamin d3
omega-3 fatty acids probiotic and
digestive enzymes this is not just
oatmeal
the protagonist is your daily wellness
insurance designed and created for
convenience whether you're running out
the door or like to prep the night
before the protagonist comes in a four
easy to whip up recipes you just add
water overnight in the fridge in the
microwave or into a smoothie and because
we want you operating at your absolute
best in addition to being plant-based
the protagonist is also gluten-free soy
and dairy-free non-gmo and allergen free
you can take it on the road when you're
traveling on a camping trip in your bag
to work at the gym and start every day
with all the energy living requires yeah
look at this i got the box right here
this is the chocolate we've got vanilla
we've got other flavors too it's
delicious you just add hot water it's so
simple and you're gonna love this stuff
hop over to
creaturesofhabit.com that's creatures
with a k
creaturesofhabit.com and use promo code
inside15
that's inside 15 to get 15 off your
first purchase
creaturesofhabit.com with a k and use
promo code inside 15 for 15 off your
first order remember we are direct
outcome of our daily habits some habits
will break you some will make you
creatures of habit is here to support
you on the journey of making greatness a
bigger part of your life
what do you sing when you're alone and
you're in the shower that's not musical
theater what is it is it do you like
like i love yacht rock i love chicago i
love foreigner sure i love the 80s i
love depeche mode
i love the i sing a lot of george
michael dude what are you saying time
can never
mean
see that the the tinnitus whispers
of a
[Music]
you know i have a friend who has a
theory that the late great george
michael may have sold his soul to the
devil
how so it's fascinating apparently
there's no record of george michael ever
taking any
uh instrumental or musical lesson ever
and yet
his first produced albums
he
is he was the instrumentalist he did he
did vocals trumpet keyboards guitar and
out of nowhere from like little there's
no no one has records of him playing
anymore he was never even in the school
choir and out of nowhere he's got this
angelic perfectly melodic fully
understood resonant voice
and uh yeah she seems to think that he's
older i've always thought that i've
always looked at some people's careers
and people who make exorbitant amounts
of money and think they sold their soul
to the devil something must be they they
did something there's something
there's something there there's
something i really believe i mean i hate
to say really believe it because it
makes me sound like a crazy person but
it's just like it's just it's just too
insane sometimes to think somebody could
be either that good yeah or you know
and it's the paganini the paganini myth
right you heard of paganini he was a
violinist that was so gifted in his time
that it wasn't a rumor it was a firm
belief in the social construct that this
man sold his soul to the devil that's
how well he played wow i love that idea
yeah yeah i like it too it's like that
whole uh
what is it the the the charlie daniels
yeah yeah yeah went down to georgia
looking for a soul to steal he was in a
bond he was way behind he was looking to
make a deal looking to make a deal what
was that what was that with the look
give the devil's dude i better fiddle a
gold against your soul cause i think i'm
better than you the boy said my name's
johnny and it might be a sin but i'll
take your bet you're gonna regret i'm
the best it's ever been
that's it anyway that's it man so did
that did your but you trained so as
opposed you didn't sell your soul to the
devil no your parents threw you in
improv they threw you in class
here's the deal i'll say this there i
have i have like isolated moments i did
i did saturday morning improv class for
nine weeks when i was nine that was a
profit nine but there was a really big i
mean i still use elements from that i
mean i always remember never to say no
right in a scene and if someone's if
someone goes off you just as long as you
don't say no the scene can carry on yes
that's still like one of the best
lessons i've ever gotten and then there
was a brief by the way what he's saying
is if you don't know because we just
skimmed over that in other words if
you're doing a scene and you're
improvising and some guy goes we are
going to the hospital you don't say no
or not we're going to the amusement park
you go with your
you listen and you go with the direction
you got to go with it so it's it's a
it's a bad thing if you if you change
direction correct and and as i said
after when puberty hit and i started
realizing i had to sort of figure out
what else i was good at i was i was on a
deep dive of i was a big
medieval history and and sword and
sandals movie buff so the
court jester led me to all the errol
flynn movies and the michael cortese
films and and and and then and then they
led me to
that also led me into into good
old-fashioned movie musicals and i
remember seeing peter o'toole in the you
know not so well conceived but but for
me nostalgically beautiful man of la
mancha right which was a big a big turn
point for me because when i saw that i
thought that's what i want to do now you
really realize i was 15 years old and i
wanted to play a 58 year old playing an
80 year old that's what and that's what
i'm still striving for but i remember i
remember viscerally
the impact it had on me because i went
to my
drama teacher in high school and i said
i want to do
we need to do man of la mancha and i
remember him saying to me i'll never
forget this mr graham god rest his soul
he was wonderful but he said to me oh no
no
you can't do that you're not a good
enough singer and and we need if we're
going to do that show we need someone
that can really sing and and i took a
year and a half
and figured out exactly what it was i
wanted to do i took some voice lessons
uh that was the year and a half that i
really took
when he said this in your mind you
immediately said i'm gonna go train yes
for something that's not even guaranteed
that they're gonna make it said no we're
not gonna do that we're not going to do
that because they picked a musical every
two years oh my god and i
i trained with a a canadian baritone and
i i learned how to control my larynx i
learned how to drop my larynx i learned
how to breathe and i learned opera and
and that foundation it was it was a good
eight months that i trained um regularly
did he know this the teacher no he
didn't no but on on the we had a school
project the following uh two years later
that was uh we had to present a song and
a scene and how old are you uh i was 17
years old 17 years old yeah just turned
17. and we had to present a song and a
scene and i i uh hired an accompanist
and i said uh i want to do mine last so
i want because we had we did two
students each class until we got through
the class i said i want to do my last
and i want a whole class give me give me
the whole class he's like well you're
only doing one scene in one song i said
i'm doing a little bit of a one-act
he said okay
and so i went in and i did i i i set up
i set the scene i did one act
of i will impersonate a man come
enter into my imagination and see him
his name alonso kihana
a country squire no longer young bony
and hollow-faced
eyes that burn with the fire of inner
vision
being retired he has much time for books
and he studies them from mourn to night
and often through the night as well and
all he reads oppresses him fills him
with indignation at man's murderous ways
towards man you are doing this to the
core class yeah
yeah and you're supposed to sing yes and
then i said no longer will he be playing
the lonzo kiana and as i'm doing this
i'm putting on a mustache and putting on
a wig and putting on the eyebrows but a
dauntless knight known as don quixote de
la mancha hear me now the bleak and
unbearable world thou art base and
debauched as can be
and a night yeah yeah full confidence
pull the whole thing you weren't even
nervous no i knew it had to be done and
when i finished my teacher said [ __ ] you
we'll do the show
and we did it and that was are you
kidding me as a 17 year old kid
yeah you have you i i don't even know i
mean i've never had drive like that
i mean it's the only thing i ever wanted
it's the only thing i've ever been
remotely good at and it still
fuels
uh
every aspect of my life i mean look
other than my children and my family my
wife
it's
really i mean it's boring it's terrible
but it's all i like
it's all i like you you love do you love
to audition
look i would love it if i knew that for
every x amount of auditions i would get
x amount of jobs
it's not that i love to audition and
it's not that i hate to audition okay um
i love
when a specific task is placed before me
and they say do you know we need to see
you do this i love that right uh and the
more specific the better for me because
because then it takes the guesswork out
i
i would love to think that after certain
displays of some skill that uh
that certain correlative projects might
not require uh so much audition and that
maybe somebody'd be like oh wait if he
could do x y and z we only need him to
do b yeah yeah bring this guy in let's
have a meeting with him sometimes it's a
little it can feel a little like gosh
really they need to see it okay but i i
i
provided it something that i think i can
add value to and that will add value to
my life that i'll enjoy doing i don't
turn down an audition because
at the end of it all i don't want to not
get a job because i was too lazy to put
my hat in the ring
do you learn lines quickly
i can't audition unless i know them all
if i'm not fully memorized i don't want
to read on it and how long will it take
you to let's say i developed a skill
recently
well not recently i developed
when i was when i was doing broadway uh
and all my les mis friends can attest to
this because i still play poker with
them every sunday when i was doing
broadway i all i used to say to the guys
was i'm gonna be a movie star one day
i'm gonna be a movie star one day i'm
gonna be moving and they used to make
fun of me they're like yeah you'll be a
movie star one day good luck
and uh i
i remember getting my first tv audition
when i was in new york for like a third
watch or something and and it was like
for two lines and i sucked because i
spent so much time like combing my hair
the way i thought the character's hair
would be i didn't even [ __ ] look at
the lines the two lines yeah i just
biffed i wasn't good and i wasn't good
because i wasn't prepared the way i
should have been prepared and i i i
remember the first time i ever got a
call back was when i memorized the line
i just memorized the lines i didn't even
give a particularly
good performance i just was looking at
the casting director and engaged in the
scene
and and and they were like oh we'd love
to see we'd love to have you come back
for the director and this like light
went off in my head like oh [ __ ] i just
need if i know my lines i'm probably
like 50 better off than the schmucks
that are that have got their faces
buried in the page and at least i'm
gratifying the writer by by showing
deference and respect to the material
and then if i can add to that some layer
of creative choice and and character
well then maybe i've got a shot at this
and and it was it was really interesting
because it was in the season that
followed that we had gone
i met my wife on the subway and we went
out to la she was an aspiring actor she
was 22 but looked like she was 16. and
so i would drive her to auditions and
they'd say your dad has to wait outside
because i was 26 and i looked like i was
40.
and and what happened though was when i
started getting some small
co-star auditions it was just being
memorized that would get me it would get
me to the next stage and that's
something just being prepared just
casting directors seeing that this guy
put the time in that's it and now we
could work with him well this is it and
it's also not egg on their face when
they bring me in for for the network or
they bring me in for a director that i'm
gonna be prepared now look i had a
friend that went to like his third
audition and he was reading a book and
when they called him and he still had
the book in his hand he didn't know the
lines and he just had the jenna say qua
and he got like a 10-year gig on some
show
i just that's never been me you know
what i mean for me me neither it did i i
always have to work it's not only it's
not only always have to work it's it's
after 35 years
i still haven't cracked
after the job is done it's literally
right back to the drawing board and i
mean it's and especially now in kovid
though i'm not auditioning for anyone i
am i'm self-taping which is effectively
it's a pre-casting
you know what i mean i'm making a tape
in my studio without any direction
and someone reading lines off camera
yeah so sometimes i'll have someone zoom
the lines in sometimes my wife will put
the baby to bed and she'll come in and
read with me and that's
horrifying because it's my wife seeing
me at my most insecure you know and and
she's she's so good and for her things
come so easily
so so it is this really amazing thing
that after all these years and after you
know you know some successes and
whatever
it still all goes back to make a tape
maybe a casting associate sees it maybe
the casting director sees it maybe they
get it to the producer maybe that you
know what i mean it's it's still that
it's it's no that's not to say that an
offer won't come here and there without
a tape but what's an offer that you have
you've had what are offers like let me
let me name something red notice did you
get an offer no no i auditioned for that
true story uh no no i haven't positioned
and then i had to have a zoom meeting as
well the kennedys
oh well actually sinatra was an offer
but it was after i had done uh 24 with
with with joel cernow but also i i
auditioned to play bobby and they liked
my bobby but but uh they hired the right
bobby they hired barry pepper who's a
great actor right uh but they they said
hey look we're not gonna have you for
bobby but do you want to be frankie and
i of course i said yeah right yeah
fantastic but what are some roles that
you
out of 10 auditions that you go out for
let's say 10 yeah how many do you get a
call back for be honest don't even even
if it's nine
be you know listen man so okay because
you work hard i could tell so i have a
feeling that you probably get called
back or you're up in the mix listen for
many many roles i i
so we are what is this we're in uh
december of 2021 right okay and we hit
the pandemic so i i came to los angeles
we left new york during the pandemic you
left new york to come to the bay in june
yes we left we left new york in june
we just had a baby and we didn't know we
were gonna live we found a house i built
a studio
we were able i was able to sort of you
know get carry on with the animation
stuff and then when auditions started to
come in i started putting myself on tape
uh between i would say between
august of 2020 and now
i i have auditioned probably on average
at least
at least two times a week two times a
week i have booked off of those
auditions
one job
two times a week since august of 2020
so
roughly
i'd say like 55 60. 55 60 auditions and
you booked one what was the one you
booked that was true story that was true
story on netflix yeah which is one of
the biggest shows now isn't it they've
done a great job man it is it's i think
it's the number one series on netflix
right now and red notice you mentioned
is the number one movie on netflix which
is great and and that was a process that
the audition for that i changed the
character to make him greek because i
wanted to find a way in that felt
organic to me
and it was all good i was set to be a
pudgy greek billionaire arms dealer and
then two and a half weeks in it was a
flag on the play rawson called me and
said that apparently ryan had done a
movie recently where there was a pudgy
greek bad guy and he was like we don't
want to do that again so he said i think
i'm going to need to recast this i said
no no no actually i was going to call
you
i've got a great idea
he should be and i and and when i sort
of pulled this out of my ass i was like
he should be
of unknown european origin and he was
like well what does he sound like i was
like well that's the thing
his dad strangled him so his voice is
broken
and he was like oh i love that we'll
call him soto voce i was like yes and
he's like and i want him to be wait a
minute this came about your character
came about in red notice
on a phone conversation
no i mean the character was written but
the but the
the new character the new and improved
character
hence i like this yes yeah i used a
little uh sean harris
uh i just love that idea of so his dad
his dad strangled him and he was left
with this paralyzed vocal cord
which i loved it's fun that's do do they
talk about in that yeah well so in there
there were
more there were more scenes that sort of
uh pointed to it you hear it in in in
subtext you hear it in some of the
dialogue and you hear it even in some of
my characters dialogue but it's sort of
a like a blink and you'll miss it uh uh
moment but yeah no all this is to say
look i i one booking
in 55 to 60 what does that tell you what
i mean if you had to
talk to fellow actors out there or
people who are trying to become an actor
how hard is it to be an actor it's it's
it's what my buddy nick wyman always
says your job is to audition just just
shut up and do the audition it's it
might be a chance for you to act you
might not have acted in a while so just
and look you asked me how i memorize
lines i do a thing where i i read
through the material all of it the the
the stage direction all the lines i read
through it as many times as it takes me
to be able to read it out loud as fast
as i possibly can read it without
tripping over a single word regardless
of whether it's my dialogue or not if i
trip over the word i have to start all
over again and i just keep doing it it's
basically like running it in italian to
do it to the point where i can speak it
so quickly that i'll never you know i i
won't i i won't trip over a single word
anymore so it's it's just it's it's
almost like you're getting you're
exhausted probably learning that's it
and in my time exhausted it's i fully
exhaust myself and then i realize oh i
totally know what the scene's about
because i've read it 100 times or 200
times or 300 times and then when i know
what the scene's about then the
pressure's off because then the lines
are there because they make sense
because the scene is very very clear i
get it i know what the character's
trying to do um but no i i mean look i i
i'm doing uh the second season of made
for love this year which is a great show
on hbo which i love and that was an
offer which was really nice and that
came about through i think through some
of my past work on hbo it came about
through silicon valley and and uh and
that's that's a real joy and it's you
know it's rare to be able to be on a
show that i watched and then didn't have
to audition for and they and they called
me in
inside of you is brought to you by geico
we love our geico look whether you rent
a home or own a home and that could be
hard work as we all know
uh you know what's easy
bundling policies with geico you see
geico makes it easy to bundle your
homeowners or renters insurance along
with your auto policy and it's a good
thing because we already have so much
damn stuff to do around the house ryan
you know it's damn true you just want to
make your life easier bundling policies
with geico geico you know the name
you're not gonna get fooled by these
guys go to geico.com get a quote see how
much you can save it's geico easy visit
geico.com today that's geico.com
inside of you is brought to you by magic
spoon
it's the new year folks and magic spoon
is perfect for meeting your goals
whether it's eating healthy or saving
more time in your morning routine
magic spoon has it all and growing up
you know cereal was one of the best
parts of being a kid ryan you remember
growing up oh i'm a red you know i'm
still doing it but you know but we had
to i had to give that up at my age i had
to give it up because i realized it's
full of sugar yeah and junk that you
really shouldn't eat yep
the cholesterol skies the your sugars
you start getting diabetes or whatever
the heck it is diabetes you know what i
mean and we're all trying to eat better
but healthy breakfast doesn't have to be
boring and that's why we have our magic
spoon magic spoon has amazing flavors
you love but without all the bad stuff
and it's amazing as a midnight snack
right before bed
you know what i mean they've got it all
zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of
protein and only four net grams of carbs
in each serving and only 140 calories
per serving it's keto-friendly
gluten-free grain-free soy-free and
low-carb and you can build your own box
available flavors to build your very own
custom bundle are cocoa fruity frosted
peanut butter blueberry cinnamon cookies
and cream and maple waffle they just
come out with more and more my flavors i
really love magic spoon magic spoon
thank you it's so easy guys people my
friends have asked me about magic spoon
i say just try it you're gonna love it
and they do and here's what you can do
you can go to magicspoon.com
iou to grab a custom bundle of cereal
and start your new year off right and be
sure to use the promo code iou at
checkout to save five dollars off your
order and magic spoon is so confident in
their product it's back with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money no questions asked remember get
your next delicious bowl of guilt-free
cereal at magicspoon.com
iou and use the code iou to save five
dollars off and thank you magic spoon
for sponsoring this episode
you know what's tough about getting an
offer for it sounds so great and it's
amazing when someone gives you an offer
for a role but um i've had this happen
where i came on set after they you know
went through the contract
worked it out one of the leads i get on
there and they want me to do something
totally different yeah so if you
audition for it and they like you it's
based on your audition you know what
you're doing yeah and then you get there
with an offer and no audition and now
they want to change things up well
you're like i don't know what the [ __ ]
i'm doing it can be tenuous i will say
for silicon valley i was such a fan of
the show that when i got the audition
for russ hanneman it was supposed to be
a two to three uh episode arc but i
loved it i was like let me in
and
i
when i auditioned for it
i had so many different versions of the
way that i wanted to do it that i gave
them
like five different i gave them like a
matt mcconaughey version where it was
kind of like a little more laid back a
little more lindsay and each take yes i
did a totally different way like what is
he doing right and yet when i got the
part and my agent called him was like it
looks like you got this part
i said find out which version they want
yeah send me the version because they're
really different [ __ ] versions yeah
and i remember and and i was like have
you asked he's like we've asked we've
asked we haven't heard anything and and
they're like okay you're on set tomorrow
i was like which [ __ ] version's gonna
be and i show up and there's mike judge
and i was like hey um uh mr judge listen
i just you know he's like oh yeah great
graham i'm glad you're here i was like
do you know which version of the of the
character you want he was like yeah yeah
i know whatever you did it's good it's
funny you're good and i was like but i
did five different ones but what i loved
about that was he was like
just go [ __ ] do it just do it yeah
you're good you think it's all that
different wasn't that different it's
still you just just do it and uh and it
was it was it was i was like okay
and then alec was like give
give us alec alec berg who by the great
alec berg [ __ ] alec berg from
seinfeld which is like the only show
that i watch when i'm in my trailer
seinfeld's on there i just saw jason
alexander on the podcast he was
brilliant he was brilliant i loved
wasn't that great he was so great oh man
i wish i could have been i am the
biggest seinfeld fan there is the
biggest seinfeld fan there is we talked
about the marine biologist
we talked about that whole episode where
they
didn't they give them that monologue at
the last time they talked about it you
talked about it can you do that
the sea was angry that day my friends no
i didn't mean that
[Laughter]
the actual scene was gonna do the scene
from uh biology no i mean can you do
that on the off the cuff listen what's
funny is the more pressure there is
attached to something the more i can
perform if it's an audition and it comes
up last minute it's like pulling [ __ ]
teeth but if i have to go on stage and
do something
i just buckle in and do it and that's
what christmas story live was because i
had this giant uh uh
no no no this huge dance number this
massive like like uh bugsby berkeley
dance number that we never rehearsed on
the actual set because it wasn't ready
until performance day that's terrifying
and the first time i did it complete
with a costume change on set and a front
flip and all of this the first time i
did it was the time that we recorded it
and it was live how was it it was
exhilarating because i did it and my
wife says there's this one moment in the
in the bloody song where you see in my
face where i've gotten through like all
of these hurdles and there's this look
in my face of like [ __ ] i just
did that like this this this matters
because you were yourself for a yes
split nuance split nuance of
holy [ __ ]
i did that yes back to the character yes
yes now back in wow yeah yeah that's
terrific do you get nervous do you get
nervous when you're on set do you get
nervous for an audition do you get
nervous in meetings to you and how do
you deal with that if you do i do i get
nervous every time um get nervous with
everything
i i have a a standard level of anxiety
and i'm a perfectionist and i
i have this thing that that that still
after all these years hasn't gone away
i'm just
i'm eager to please i just want it all
to go right i know i want it
yeah i and i think that's that's
i had a friend recently that said to me
you can afford to be cocky and i was
like i can't i can't because right when
i think i can be cocky about something
particularly in the industry it's so
ephemeral it goes
it's the hardest thing to get and it's
the easiest thing to lose that that the
moment that you love so yes i do get
nervous i i step onto set i feel good i
feel prepared i think the more prepared
i can be the less nervous i'll feel it's
the wild cards that throw me i'm fully
prepared i know what i'm doing i got
everything and then a director will come
up and give me a note that's so left
field of anything i thought it would
make your nerves kind of piece oh it's
just this notion of oh [ __ ] like i've
got this all figured out completely
wrong
and and so that makes me nervous
auditions now are very different than
they were but you know going in to meet
producers or going into a to a test to
meet you know studio executives that's a
nerve-wracking experience because
they're also asking you to do something
that's so inorganic to what the actual
end result is you know the end result is
you're on a set that's closed and you're
doing a performance that's nuanced and
small and for the screen when you go in
to book these massive jobs you're in a
board room you know with all of these
executives around the table and you're
giving a performance right that that you
know you have to nuance in the right
direction it it can't be what you're
going to ultimately do on the day
because they're small yes there's no
charisma there you know they can't see
it and it can't be uh hi everybody
welcome to the show you know what i mean
because then they're going to be like oh
it's too big so it really is i mean look
with stooges
oh my god i couldn't i remember testing
for the fairly brothers for that i
remember going in a room and there was
sean hayes and there was like so i bet
you were there how many auditions did
you have i had three i had one where i
sent my tape in to one of the producers
then they brought me in and then i came
in with a bunch of uh you guys
i have i still have the audition and i
i'm proud of it i had a wig and i was
like you know you [ __ ] killed it i
had 14 over six months fourteen dude
when i heard about this i called my oh
my man
and i said i'm the biggest huge fan
there is i gotta go in and i gotta go do
this and she said you're not a celebrity
and you're not a comedian i don't think
i can get you an appointment and it was
a friend of mine that called me that was
like hey are you going to the stooges
thing and i was he's like you're a
student fan right i was like yeah
he's like are you going i was like yeah
yeah when are you going he's like i'm
going on friday i was like yeah where is
that he's like well i was like where is
it again did you just show up yep
you hold on a second you had no audition
no agent representation going into that
i mean you had an agent i had an agent
but you just you just signed in i went
to a hasidic
wig shop and bought a wig i cut a wig i
went to a foam latex foam store and i
padded my neighbor's suit my neighbor's
much bigger than me so that i could lose
my neck and fill out some girth
and i got to the audition
and at the audition there was a big sign
that said do not come in character
and i walked in there and i saw these
guys and jeans and a t-shirt and i was
like what the how the [ __ ] are they
going to find mo larry and curly
like looking like this is ridiculous and
so when the casting director came out i
remember it was rick montgomery he
opened the door and he went hey
he looked at me and cautioned it was a
ridiculous [ __ ] costume but he was
just like oh god
all right come on in and i and i went in
and it was one there was one page of
sides it was just one page of sides i
didn't know you had that little bowl cut
i had the bowl cut and i didn't do the
sides i did a i did uh
uh i did a bunch of little things from
from the shorts you you know you see
that store over there each one of us
grab a broom we go out and we sweep in
front of the place the boss comes out
sees three conscientious guys and offers
us a job it's simple come on get going i
did i did all this [ __ ] and they were
like huh and then and then they were
like okay come back
um and and and i got a note and they
were like your costume's terrible
so you if you're going to come in
costume you got to do something better
so i hired christian tinsley who did the
makeup for the passion of the christ
and i got him to do under eye bags on me
and a full face cast and i
my wife was doing a show warner brothers
[ __ ] went
above and beyond what anybody else would
do and you didn't even have an audition
i had to get you didn't have i had to
get it i was the guy i had to i had to i
had to get it and i i i broke into the
warner brothers costume warehouse and i
borrowed a fat suit and period clothes
and i
went back over and over and over again
they kept bringing me back kept bringing
me back kept bringing me back and then
i wouldn't hear anything in costume and
like i never went out not only in
costume in character
sign in and hi hi boss how you doing i
never ever ever people looking at you
like yes they thought i was a [ __ ]
lunatic and and who cares
and pete was pete would go
well it's mo it's mo and and bob and
bobby was like yeah you do you you got
the mo thing i was like oh thank you
very much and they were like
all right all right and i would anytime
i'd go in i'd try and find a moment to
do something slap sticky like in one of
my auditions i pretended i didn't see
the chair i fell right over it and uh
and they all got it from their chairs
like they thought it really happened and
and it it every moment was a chance to
show them a little bit more that i
understood the stooges but dude i got my
heart broken so many times because i
remember reading variety right after an
audition
right after one of the auditions that
johnny knoxville got the part and i was
like oh my god
and then and it turns out pete told me
that he did have the part they offered
it to him he accepted and then
pete and johnny had a talk and johnny
was like well i'm not gonna do an
impression because i don't that's not
what i do it's going to be like the
modern mo and pete was like no no this
is the stooges
and and johnny was like i'm not sure
this is going to work and so then they
went back to the drawing board and they
more auditions and then i i
read sorry then my manager called and
said
i'm sorry it's the end of the line they
have offered it to hank as area
and they had and uh and he would have
been one they just kept going they saw
moe right in front of them and they kept
going around but he wanted too much
money and i wrote a letter
uh to the head of fox at the time
basically a plea for why they should
hire me and in the letter i said i'll do
it for free don't pay me
and uh and they didn't they took me up
on it man yeah it cost me money to do
that movie because i had to move my
newborn and my wife to atlanta for 16
weeks and and i got paid
what was it schedule schedule f is that
true yeah yeah they really didn't pay
you no they paid you as minimal as they
could for being the star of the movie
the lowest i could have possibly what is
that what is schedule f tell people with
schedule that happens i got three
schedule f is [ __ ] off i got 32 000
for for for that movie
16 weeks in atlanta and it's probably
costing you half that to live there oh
yeah no no it cost us it i think it cost
us i ended up
factoring it cost me about 16 000
to keep the place in los angeles move to
atlanta and you know and be there was it
a dream come true though
it was you know i it's funny man it
wasn't a perfect movie um but it was a
perfect experience how are the fairly
brothers to work with they're lovely you
know they're they're they're salt of the
earth guys they are they're the
antithesis of any sort of
um auteurs right but they still create
memorable uh um uh massively globally
impactful movies right but they do it
without any pretense they're they are
exactly what you would expect them to be
um and they're um
they were there it was it was a unique
singular and marvelous experience and
sean will and i will be forever
connected in in that regard i mean those
are the those
shawn and will if they ever call or need
anything or i i it's i'm they're they're
how did they get away with giving you
schedule f for a studio film i i've just
never heard that before schedule f is
something that you hear about with
independent movies
or did you just say i want this don't
even bother i was so listen man that's
crazy it's crazy it's funny right but
but how often in our lives forget about
our careers as actors but how often in
our lives are we ever faced
with an opportunity
to
uh inhabit and pay homage to something
that had a massive impact on us as
children i mean to really be a part of
something you got to understand it
wasn't like i was oh yeah i like the
stooges no no no no i had my brother for
christmas when i was 13 got me the the
print of molari and curly on the golf
course it was on my it was on my wall
like i mean i was upset i was obsessed
with the stooges so
uh yeah you know i remember i don't even
remember
care when they called they're like this
is the offer i was like right yeah i got
the offer you know what i mean and as a
matter of fact
this is a good story
please this is a good story
i didn't get the offer
oh my god i can't [ __ ] believe this
happened i'm still remembering it
yeah so
i don't hear anything after my last
audition
i don't hear anything and then and
you're going crazy i'm going nuts and
then i get a call from from my agent who
said it looks like they want to do a
proper screen test with you sean and
will
and pete and bob are gonna do this on
the fox lot
and and pete called me and said listen
the studio is starting to waffle
on
how they feel about bringing this movie
forth
and we feel like we want to show them
exactly what we want to do so we want to
make a scene a proper scene from the
movie and he said no pressure but this
really is he said and i said i said wait
what does this mean he goes doesn't mean
you got the part
but i want you to do this with us and
it's going to kind of live or die on if
this works so you'll get the part but if
it doesn't work we're not making the
[ __ ] movie so
you know no pressure so i go and you
drive the scene i'm sure mo drives all
the scenes yes
mo definitely did drive the scene and we
did the scene and it was great
but then i don't hear anything i forgot
two and a half [ __ ] no one calls you
but i'm dying and at this point my
stomach is like eating itself okay
and i get a call i'll never forget this
i'm driving through laurel canyon right
around here right and the reception is
for [ __ ] oh yeah thank you okay and i
get a call and i can and it's a 3-0
number that i don't recognize and i pull
over and and uh oh is this mo and i said
yeah it's pete farrelly and i said
i said hi he goes well well what the
hell man are you doing our movie or not
and i and i was like wait what he goes
you
you you got the offer you know right
and
i said no no wait what oh oh my god
thank you and he's like call your agent
so i called my agent
and my agent says yeah well yeah no we
got the offer it's it's a shitty offer
they came in with no money and i was
like wait
wait
i've been going so
my entire life i've been working toward
getting this role six months i've
auditioned for this thing 14 times and
we got the offer and you didn't tell me
well no no we were going to tell you
today and i
i i snapped snapped
and
i it was it was just this
okay you're fired it's not like
it's done you fired them i had are you
kidding how co i mean
it's it's this it's your dream and
they're [ __ ] come on now listen i
understand and by the way i would have
loved it if they doubled the offer or
tripled it or whatever the hell it but
call me call me this is your dream this
is my [ __ ] dream slaving in there
dying dying and it was the middle of
pilot season two where in between these
auditions i would go in and make it to
studio and not make it to network or
make it to network and i was the second
choice or make it to studio make it to
network i'm the choice and then the
pilot doesn't happen you know what i
mean so you fired them on that call it
happened right then and there you said
you're fired and what'd they say and
they said you're overreacting and i said
i've never been more sanguine in my life
in my career
you're fired and and i it wasn't an easy
thing because i really liked my agents
uh i wouldn't have used the word
sanguine because i'm not exactly sure
what it means
but i applaud you
for for doing that that i mean
chutzpah i had to i had to for for my
nine-year-old self and for my 90 year
old self i had to
yeah did you ever meet anybody related
to mo or any family numbers i did there
was a time where will and i were invited
to philadelphia for i think it was a
stooge convention in honor of larry and
i met mose
i want to say i met moe's daughter
and i met some of his family and they
even gave me the most beautiful mo moe
made uh clay and ceramic things uh uh
you still have them i have this
beautiful bathtub that he made with his
little signature mo face on the bottom
of it okay that's it's one of my little
precious little do you have the poster
in your house uh i do yeah i have it in
my studio actually you have a studio
yeah yeah what other things do you have
in your studio i have my first the first
ever drawing of my mickey mouse that
paul rudis did for me
uh which which is marvelous i have uh
some renderings of my darkwing duck
which which i did uh for for for
ducktales i i did a pilot where i was
going to be
the new dark wing uh from mickey mouse
audition by the way how many how did you
go in and say like two lines no no no no
that was so i i think i'm not sure if i
mentioned this but i you know i passed
on it at first right right yeah yeah
yeah but but it was um we went to the
old animation building and i had to
re-voice the entire brave little tailor
so it was all the original original
score and original voices other than you
know me going in and doing waltz ah yes
your honor and how i was all alone i
heard them coming i looked up they were
here there everywhere a whole bunch of
them yeah i had to redo the whole thing
and then they
they re-voiced that old animation it's
one of the most exhilarating things i've
ever done holy [ __ ] you've got to do
some cool [ __ ] things yeah i i am i
got a horseshoe i mean you portray robin
williams behind the camera which i have
to see now like how hard is that to
portray i mean he's so
physical so
so nuanced so all over the place i
remember my manager at the time called
and said so there's this he's like look
these movies are sort of these salacious
you know behind the scenes of three's
company or charlie's angels or whatever
it is he's like they're doing a mork and
mindy one
it's like a low budget thing they're
gonna shoot it in vancouver in like 12
13 days or whatever it is but they need
a robin williams and they can't find it
and and i remember saying and my wife is
usually the one to sort of remind me why
i do what i do i was like
i was like i love robin williams i i
adore him but i'm not robin i don't look
anything like the guy i don't sound
anything like him and she said okay well
who would you cast i was like i don't
know like jim carrey or whatever i i i
would i wouldn't she said who would you
cast she said jim carrey's not gonna do
a 500 000 movie who would you cast i
said i don't know she goes well if you
don't know then you should audition for
it
and and and i went on a deep dive i i i
i i you know looked at all the inside
the actor's studio stuff and i looked at
all this old stand-up and there was some
stand-up tapes that my brother had my
older brother that were way too old for
me that i remember watching some of his
stuff in san francisco and uh and and i
realized that man i was a huge robin
williams fan i mean i i
i was really really
engaged in what he did uh from stand up
to all of his movies and i remember when
goodwill hunting came out i had that on
a loop on in my vhs i watched it over
and over and over and over again right
so i guess a lot sort of
sort of by osmosis
sort of impacted how i i was able to
sort of recreate that and i realized
when i was able to find his voice
and how he sort of held himself and how
he how he talked and and
and sort of there was kind of a quiet
element to him and
and how he
he really didn't he really didn't want
the attention but well he would take it
i mean joke me if you can't take a [ __ ]
and there was this this sort of geez
it's so good
it was this moment of like oh [ __ ] like
all right well his shoulders were higher
and that affects how he sounds and
and he had kind of a
a very kind and almost a pleasant his
lips were there was this and it was like
oh [ __ ] if i can i think i might be able
to do that and and so i thought okay but
the only way i'm gonna do this is if i
can look in the mirror and see it so i
hired a wig maker and i went to my
optometrist and i got contact lenses
made and and i found
rainbow suspenders and i walked around
the city in new york like that for a
week and got on the bus and thanks chief
okay i'll see you later and and and sort
of lived it and then i went to the
audition fully in character and i
remember it was stephen o'neill in nbc
and it was at the rockefeller center and
you had to like sign in and i fully went
in in character and and stephen had seen
me for a million other things and he was
like hi chris and i was like oh hello
and he was like oh christ like he was
just like what are you doing but i
didn't break it and i went in and i had
a whole routine set up and i also
realized because i had the script for
that that crazy that they all the
impressions that they had in there they
weren't going to be able to use them
because it was an unauthorized biography
and all those impressions were things
that he had done and i knew that they
were going to be in trouble so i came up
with all these impressions that we
hadn't seen him do
and uh and it all ended up in the film i
had a real that was a turning point and
you were
like i can't do this i couldn't even do
an impression yeah and in the beginning
you really didn't have any idea how to
do this guy no zero and and it wasn't
until
i watched goodwill hunting again and
realized i'd remember i mean i knew that
entire film inside out and backwards
that
it was like oh gosh i actually do
understand his cadence where he
resonates how he speaks and i know it
sounds like such a surfacy thing just
finding the voice
but but it's i want you it's so funny
because i'm like i i wish that we
weren't on this podcast right now
because i'd want you to teach me how to
do it it's it's it's it's a it's it's
it's physiognomy so if if if if you can
if you can look i suppose
how do you do that in your arms and
you're like
well it's well it's yeah there's there's
you know it's funny it's it's watching
what his mouth and his lips and his
tongue and his face and
and where he resonated and and and and
he would also sort of change it some
when he did his mork it would it would
shift and it's how he would shift so you
have to look like him to sound like it
was a really nice yeah but then it's
also like if you don't want it to just
be an snl sketch right you want it to
actually be a living breathing human
being so there are other elements too i
could talk to you forever it's fun this
is funny this is like i'm like i haven't
even looked at any notes or anything
it's just so exciting to hear like what
you do and what you what you what you do
to go after a role and what it takes to
really be an actor and it makes me feel
like
i i just haven't done enough no that's
not well i mean look i've done like i
feel like i've done some good work in my
life done some stuff that no one has
seen but at the same time like i look at
an actor like you and you really
really put in the work and you don't
question it you really go after it i'm
pathological about it though and and i
do have to say i don't think it's the
only way in i i think that they're
they're
look you have done remarkable work
you've done lasting work and and
i i don't think that there's i think
there are there are many ways to get to
the end i think for me
i i'm i've been so
moved by the
performances in movies and tv that have
shaped who i am
that i
look at every opportunity that i am on
screen as a chance to do something that
could
end up
being that for someone right so
i i i look and i talk to my agents about
this all the time they'll be like oh
it's just an audition it's coming in
it's up to it's tomorrow it's like you
don't know how much effort i put into
these auditions it's not just an
audition yeah it's a it's a real
performance for me i give a piece of
myself and it sounds cheesy but it's
true yeah i don't i mean
when they say hey you get an audition
tomorrow it's like i need a few days
yeah it's a lot i mean i've recently
i've i've because i'm taping by myself
i've come up with a way where i have a
screen and if it's last minute and i
have to do it i'll even put the sides up
on a screen and how do you do that yeah
so that's that's you know finding an eye
mark on the screen with the sides and
and framing my hand out of where where
the mouse is and just and scrolling
through and finding a way to do it but i
will have to say i do have to say that
it's not as good i'd say
i'd say
like 19 times out of 20 i i end up
scrapping it and telling them if they if
they if you can give me an extra couple
of days i'll learn it and i'll do it but
there there have been a few times where
it's like oh [ __ ] has it ever worked
yeah uh i don't know that it's ever
worked that i've booked anything from it
has it ever worked
yes it actually has it did work red
notice no it wasn't red notice no no it
wasn't what was it it was uh i did a
small part for this upcoming uh daisy
jones and the six that amazon is doing
uh and it was a last minute thing it was
just a quick thing but i didn't have
time to memorize it they wanted it that
day i did it and um and and i got it so
that was fun and then you learned it and
then i learned it yeah jeez
i mean there's i mean you've done so
many things you always appear in all
these things i mean you're playing you
know uh
opposite gal you say gal gadot i do say
gal gadot is it gal gadot i i think it's
gadot gadot i think that's what it is
ryan i'm going with gadot it sounds good
to me yeah and ryan reynolds and the
rock and you're working with all these
great people and it's just like the more
i talk to you the more i feel like
of course you are
you should be working with all these
people i it's you should be i i really
truly as corny as it sounds do feel like
it's we're lucky to get up and be able
to do this for a living and and you know
i i i of course i want to keep
progressing and i want to keep growing
and doing more things uh but i also just
i really just want to keep moving my my
wife always says to me just keep your
head down and do good work and and and
because the rest of it is all it it's
it's vapor it's all vapor right you know
when you think about the lauded
performances from 1989 i mean like it it
it doesn't matter unless the experience
is meaningful
because all of
it's all air it's just it doesn't it
doesn't exist
uh so we might as well
joke them if they can't take a [ __ ] if
like if they can't take a [ __ ] is that
what he said yeah well just [ __ ] up
truck [ __ ] them if they can't take a
joke and he flipped it joke them if they
can't take a [ __ ] which is brilliant if
they can't pick a [ __ ]
how was that it's pretty good it's
pretty good yeah well i need a lot of
work
this is uh
by the way you gotta promise me
if you're ever up for an oscar
okay you get you know one of these
things you gotta come back in the
podcast no matter how big you get okay
so i i'll make the deal so but we have
to double edge that deal so the deal is
a hundred percent
next david letterman if you become the
next david letterman i'm i'm your first
[ __ ] guy you could be the first
guest right thank you that's it okay
good all right
this is called
[ __ ] talking with chris diamantopoulos
did i say that right you said it right
that [ __ ] just got it you got it you
said it like my mother these are my
patrons these are patreons who pay extra
for the podcast they support it they
love the podcast they want it to
continue they give back so they get to
ask some questions great nico i'm first
generation greek america i was wondering
if there were any greek traditions your
friends here had a hard time wrapping
their heads around when you were growing
up mine were name days oh yeah name days
are nico bravo nico
charisto
i said thanks nick thanks for the
question um yeah you know my my canadian
friends growing up always felt like it
was weird to see a
full skinned lamb on a spit in my
backyard in april during easter because
we've reversed the skin lamb on the spit
yeah we roast a lamb and it's not just
like you know it's you're not like
barbecuing lamb piece it's like a full
with the eyes and the teeth like it's a
full beast but we ate everything and uh
yeah so my my friends were always like
uh that's really that's really intense
there's a lamb on a spit a lamb a full
lamb on a spit is a lot to look at uh
wow uh maddie s uh loved how outrageous
your character was in red notice how did
you prepare for the role that's a nice
question and thanks for the comment but
yes well you know what i i'll just say
this i had to i had two weeks to get
into the best physical shape of my life
two weeks yeah
and uh i
i fasted which i hadn't really done
before does that really work yes how how
now explain the fast yeah so you wake up
you wake up and when do you eat what's
so time do you so this is what i would
do i would wake up and and try to wake
up as late as possible because the
longer you sleep the less you're awake
and you're not eating
i would drink lots of water i would
drink black coffee
and i would go for walks and drink water
and drink coffee and go for walks and
then when it was about six or seven pm
i would break my fast with some uh
grass-fed red meat
and then i would
go to sleep again and fast again and you
lost weight and got tight and ripped
yeah i mean i probably lost i probably
only lost about like
maybe eight or nine pounds but uh
because i was training at the same time
everything just sort of vacuum sealed
and and i i worked out every day for two
weeks i didn't actually the surprising
thing is that it's it's
99 diet is is in terms of in terms of
cinematic aesthetics of looking good on
screen it's really what you eat not the
gym i i trained once or twice a week
that's it by the way i'm just this is
completely
uh irrelevant to what we're talking
about yes but i'm watching you now and
i'm thinking there's a great impression
that you probably can do that you should
do if not you should play this guy okay
someday in a movie
you should play johnny carson you know i
was thinking the same thing actually i
was thinking you know they should do
i i i was i would i was off the top of
my head they should do a limited series
where i play johnny carson look at this
i just looked at you and i was like you
got to be johnny carson you know i i do
you do impressions of johnny carson
you've done that many times i have not
but i will tell you this i had heard
that there is something percolating out
there i i i want to say you
embody
carson you have this like i don't know
what it is i know something relaxed out
there and i think i think it's adam uh
adam
mckay yes who's doing it um i did not
know that weird wild stuff great show
tonight yes
yeah yeah no i i uh uh adam mckay if
you're listening come on throw throw a
good greek canadian kid a bone here and
let me let me in the room i used to uh
ed mcmahon
i worked with a man on this crappy tv
show that i did back in 98 called the
tom show was with tom arnold ed mcmahon
that wasn't a crappy show that was a fun
show no no it was really bad she was
ranked 138 at 137
that's the kind of material i'm into but
i said i i used to say to ed every day
ago and it was so cold this morning he
goes how cold was it
so cold i saw robin putting his worm in
the microwave
weird wow stuff
so but you you nail it wow uh leanne
what character that you have portrayed
are you the most like oh that's a great
question uh mickey mouse i was gonna say
that was mickey mouse uh yeah yeah
probably i think so what character that
i've portrayed well it's probably a
combination of uh
moe and mickey mouse because i'm i'm not
that bright but i've got a lot of gum
[ __ ] i think you're bright you use
segwine
sanguine sanguine
that's what i'm telling you you're
segwayed to the sanguine yeah exactly
jill e what is better the rocks tequila
ryan reynolds gin or trace kamas tequila
come on now listen sorry dj sorry ryan
but let's all be honest and you gotta
try it so my character on on silicon
valley has his this tequila called tres
comas right the three comma club because
he's a billionaire he's this obnoxious
billionaire well we actually made the
tequila and sold it for a period of time
and surprisingly enough it was delicious
really yeah yeah if you can find a
bottle of it i highly recommend it
trace commerce
danny did chris enjoy that's you yes did
you enjoy the physical comedy aspects of
playing marky bark um
oh that was marvelous listen i enjoyed
being in the presence of mitch hurwitz
yeah i worked with him too very smart
guy not only smart but just a prince and
there was something about him he's so um
mozart-like in his understanding of what
the over all scope of the of the of not
only the episode but the whole series
was going to be that he would throw
things out from behind the camera that
felt like these like random suggestions
but he knew how he was going to weave
them into his story i loved that yeah
and and and the character was this
beautiful clueless but i love characters
that are completely unaware of how
clueless they are and and that was
really really fun to play and such great
collaborators on that entire set that
was marvelous well i mean it's it's
incredible i mean you get red notice on
netflix which is is just kicking ass on
netflix since the biggest netflix movie
ever i mean that's incredible crazy and
true story which is isn't it also doing
great it's the number one series on
netflix right now diary of a wimpy kid
oh yeah that and that's coming out at
disney plus on on december 3rd and
that's just terrific for people that
love that franchise inside job that's a
great adult animated show on netflix
it's super fun i mean you netflix loves
you well i'm fortunate man i'll take it
because i it's funny when you know when
it's time to open a bottle of wine and
have dinner in front of the tv that's
what we're putting on this is just
incredible i mean the amount of work
you've done what you're doing there's no
stopping you man i i love it i love how
humble you are but you're also a lot of
fun you haven't lost that that kid's
spirit the inner child you could see it
come out and you can see how much fun
you have entertaining thanks man you
know it's it's really cool man it's
really cool you make it really easy this
is a great for all the actors out there
listening that that are that are gonna
be invited here i highly recommend it
this is this is like the best interview
i've done this is fun really yeah well
holy [ __ ] yeah so so yeah let's let's i
i'm looking forward to you taking over
the tonight show and me winning the
oscar
[Laughter]
oh this has been fun ryan do you have
anything
no this has been i didn't know they made
trace comes tequila though you gotta you
gotta get on that yeah because i missed
that ryan [ __ ] well you're ryan [ __ ]
yeah that's true ryan fox if you don't
know what we're talking about it's on
silicon valley it's his character it's
ryan fox
this has been a really big treat you're
going to come back in the podcast right
my pleasure i would love to have you
back on i'd love to hang out with you
sometime you're you're a great guy be
fun feeling's mutual man thanks for
allowing me to be inside of you yeah
absolutely
wait where have i heard that before uh
his show yes yes exactly all right i'm
gonna have to give you a tumbler an
insighty tumbler oh i want one for sure
i'll give it to you now yeah all right
let's go
uh that was one of my favorite
interviews i think you could tell i it
was really just
it was effortless i am not over the
robin williams impression just sitting
in here listening to it just watching
him transform on
[ __ ] real
uh but he's been doing it his whole life
so i mean yeah well i better be good at
it yeah well he's uh
i really liked him that guy [ __ ]
that guy [ __ ] what was that on silicon
valley silicon valley that when he said
that famous line
um again thank you follow us on our
handles inside of you podcast on twitter
and instagram insideipod on the facebook
is that right mm-hmm
and then go to patreon.com inside you if
you want to support the podcast a little
more i i welcome you to go there i think
he'll dig it you can give anything to
the podcast 50 cents quarter a dollar
whatever you want i mean you know it
just helps podcast
uh
and the inside of you online store got
tons of great stuff uh lex miss scripts
signed by me smallville lunch boxes
inside you sh uh
shirts i believe i think we got so many
tumblers and we've got lots of great
stuff there so check all that out thank
you for coming to our stage at this last
weekend we hadn't played in a while so
if we were a little rough i apologize
but uh you know it uh i thought we we we
had a lot of fun and it was a lot of fun
seeing everybody there
so uh thank you for attending and maybe
you could bring someone to the next show
at the end of uh
this next month
um there you go right now we're gonna
read the top patrons great why don't we
do that let's do it we love doing that
don't we we do i love these patrons
okay nancy d leah
f
what f s s
sarah
v little lisa you kiko jill e brian h
nico
p robert
uh b jason w kristen k amelia o allison
l raj c joshua d cj p jennifer and stacy
l jen
p
jen
i don't know
when you miss one i go i do 10 by myself
fine jamal f
janelle b roger s mike eldon zapremo 99
more amira santiago am chad
d
no w chad w you got the w i can do that
leanne p janine r maya p matty s belinda
and chris
uh d
h and also dave
h dave hall yeah spider-man chase sheila
g brad d ray h tabitha t tom
and
liliana a michelle
k
g
l and chad l rochelle nathan e marion
meg
k trav l dan
uh
and yes big stevie w angel
you're blowing me away today
angel m i don't know yeah rhiannon c
cory
i don't know okay super
sam coleman
coolers coleman g dev
nixon michelle a jeremy c cody r
sebastian k gav
inator david
uh d c
c john b brandy d yeah vore camille
ass
the c correct joey m willie f christina
e adelaide n omar i lena ann eugene and
leah chris p nikki g cory patricia maria
ann heather l jake b bobbitt ed a eddie
hey we do that every time at a
ablef tony g and sean r i couldn't do
the uh podcast without you patrons thank
you for supporting the podcast on the
side i hope you're still enjoying
patreon and um thanks for being my
patrons thank you for uh watching the
show today or listening you could listen
anywhere you get podcasts obviously
you're listening but please get friends
tell if you like the podcast then get
your